respektvoll ist glaube ich in der Tat
ein gutes Stichwort und es geht um den
Respekt vor dem souverän vor dem Volk
vor dem Wähler und dem was wir am
26.09.2021 hier in Berlin erlebt haben
die sprichwörtlichen chaos-wahlen die
jetzt ja endlich nach einem Jahr von
Berliner Verfassungsgerichtshof
aufgegriffen worden ich habe sie wenige
Tage nach der Wahl damals angefochten
weil ich dachte das entspricht nicht
demokratischen Standards das kann keinen
Bestand haben nach etwas mehr als einem
Jahr hat sich der Verfassungsgerichtshof
auch zumindest schon mal in der Tendenz
dahingehend geäußert dass das so sein
soll und jetzt ist aus meiner Sicht auch
die spannende Frage hat Berlin
eigentlich gegenwärtig überhaupt ein
normal durch das Grundgesetz bzw
Verfassung legitimiertes Parlament oder
sitzen da in Anführungszeichen
scheinparlamentarium
und ich bin der Auffassung dass sowohl
der Verfassungsgerichtshof als auch der
Wahlprüfungsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages diese Frage ja letztlich zu
entscheiden haben zum Ergebnis kommen
müssen dass die Wahlen sowohl Bundestag
als Abgeordnetenhaus in ganz Berlin
wiederholt werden müssen und auch nicht
wie jetzt den Bundestag in einzelnen
Wahlkreisen und das selbstverständlich
in dem Moment in dem das
Verfassungsgericht das feststellt die
Parlamentarier die dort in
Anführungszeichen dann nicht hingehören
auch auseinandertreten müssen und das
letzte legal gewählte Parlament an deren
Stelle treten muss die Frage im übrigen
was wir haben ja zwei Ebenen Landtag und
Bundestag was den Bundestag angeht wenn
der dritte Wahlkreis der Linkspartei in
zwei sind ja in Berlin gewonnen worden
ich bin der eine von beiden tatsächlich
der eher wackelig war neu gewählt werden
müsste würde das ja nicht nur dazu
führen dass die Linken aus dem Parlament
fallen würden weil sie die
Sonderregelung eben halt nicht mehr in
Anspruch nehmen können sondern es würde
auch dazu führen dass sich der Deutsche
Bundestag Versand verkleinert weil die
ausgleichs- und Überhangmandate
wegfallen werden wir hätten also genau
alles erreicht was der Bundestag
vorgeblich angeblich will und ich glaube
das ist auch wiederum der Grund warum
sich im Wahlprüfungsausschuss im Moment
keine Mehrheit dafür findet wirklich
gesamt Berlin neu zu wählen wir fragen
die Frösche ob sie das Wasser im Teich
ablassen wollen
Füße wenn man das nicht so anhört ich
möchte nicht das Wort Bananenrepublik
sein das hat zum Glück e der
FDP-Politiker Sebastian Scheyer gesagt
deswegen kann ich jetzt wiederholen aber
wenn sie jetzt darauf blicken sind wir
in diesem speziellen Fall eine
bananenrepa also ich finde es allerhand
dass wir wenn schon wir nicht wissen wie
Demokratie funktioniert dass wir uns
aufschwingen und der Ukraine erklären
wollen wie Ukraine oder den Russen
erklären wollen wie Ukraine zu
funktionieren hat also es ist schon ein
Armutszeugnis dass der Flughafen nicht
fertig wird 20 Jahre lang oder wie lange
das gedauert hat und das auch jetzt wie
in Südamerika die Wahlen nicht richtig
also es ist schon es geht auch hier geht
steil bergab mit uns und ich muss sagen
Deutschland das reiche Deutschland das
tüchtige Deutschland
bye bye darling bye bye hier muss ich
einmal Herrn Knabe fragen ob sie uns zum
Schluss dieser Sendung der noch etwas
aufmunterndes mitgeben können damit wir
jetzt nicht aus der Sendung aussteigen
mit bye bye Deutschland das würde mich
jetzt zu sehr deprimieren für heute
Abend ja es gibt hoffentlich Neuwahlen
in Berlin und auch auf Bundesebene und
dann werden die Karten neu gemischt das
ist ja so dass bei sind keine Neuwahlen
sondern wiederholungswahlen das führt
dazu dass die selben Köpfe wieder
kandidieren wie im letzten Jahr und da
hat jeder die Möglichkeit jeder Wähler
das Kreuz an einer anderen Stelle zu
machen
das ist auch ihre Hoffnung sie haben das
Schlusswort
wir werden nicht umhin kommen diese
Wahlwiederholung durchzuführen
denn wenn das einmal geschehen würde und
so durchgeht dann kann es an jeder
Stelle wiederholt werden und ich glaube
da sind wir uns auch bei allen anderen
inhaltlichen Differenzen absolut einig
Demokratie kann nur dann funktionieren
wenn sie tatsächlich bis ins letzte
Detail auch genauso gelebt wird und
jeder sie engagiert verteidigt